so Davos God's named King snore isn't it
no that doesn't sound right King John
it doesn't my I forgive me but may I ask
a question of course your name is Jon
Snow but your father's name was Ned
Stark I'm busted my mother and father
weren't married what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to talking
Thrones today I'm gonna talk about one
of the biggest secrets in the Seven
Kingdoms and when this gets revealed in
the television show it's gonna be an
absolute bombshell that is gonna
completely change everything I know some
of you aren't gonna believe this but
trust me this is gonna happen this
season without a doubt and for those of
you that I've been following my channel
for a very long time you already know
how accurate the leaks are that I have
been reporting on for over the past nine
months all the information in this video
comes from the same person who leaked
all the previous information about each
episode this season and I have read it
all and so far it has been surprisingly
100 percent accurate but I will still
let all of you be the judge we will find
out if any of this is true or not in a
few days when episode 5 airs there will
be a few massive spoilers in this video
so make sure you proceed with caution
let's begin I will give a brief
backstory on the theory first because
there were a few people that commented
on my last video that didn't know what I
meant when I said R plus L equals J some
people that watch these videos aren't as
familiar with everything that some of us
are so I won't assume everyone has
watched and read everything a hundred
times like we have but I'm gonna try and
make this quick I will put a little
clock on the screen right now just in
case you want to skip the backstory and
just get straight to the leak one of the
biggest secrets in this story in
television show revolve around who Jon
Snow's true parents actually are and
still to this day this is a hot debate
but when it comes to the characters in
this story in show pretty much everyone
that knows Jon Snow just assumes he is
Ned Stark's bastard son because Ned had
brought back in baby from the war
claiming it was his child but he would
never tell anyone who Jon's mother was
he wouldn't even tell his wife her best
friend who was the king the reason being
was because Ned knew if Robert ever
found out who
John's real parents were he would have
had John killed immediately robert
baratheon was madly in love with Ned
Stark's sister Lyanna stark and in fact
Lyanna stark was actually betrothed to
Robert Baratheon meaning they were
supposed to get married but Lyanna stark
was never in love with Robert Baratheon
she ended up falling in love with
another man and this led to Robert's
rebellion and the birth of John Snow one
of the most famous stories in Westeros
is what happened during the turning of
Harrenhal
there was a huge justing tournament and
nearly everyone was there it might as
well have been a red-carpet event
because anyone who was rich and powerful
and famous was there the Mad King was
there and his son Rhaegar Targaryen was
there Rhaegar Targaryen was actually
competing in this tourney in he even won
and when it was over he was given blue
winter roses and he was to crown the
most beautiful woman that was there in
attendance
Rhaegar wife Elia Martell was there so
everyone assumed Rhaegar would give the
Roses to her but he actually rode right
past her and laid the roses in lyanna's
lap instead and this shocked the crowd
because they were sure he would give
them to his wife but he had his eyes set
on a stark Lyanna stark some time had
passed since the tournament in Rhaegar
and Lyanna actually ended up going
missing and everyone assumed Rhaegar
must had kidnapped Ned Stark's sister
and was holding her somewhere against
her will that's when Ned Stark Allen
Reid and a few other bannermen actually
tracked them down and found out they
were shacked up in the Tower of joy but
Rhaegar wasn't there
Rhaegar had left the tower and he ended
up being killed by Robert Baratheon at
the Trident Robert Baratheon was furious
because he loved Leone a stark so much
and Robert thinks Rhaegar kidnapped and
raped Leone over and over again but that
was not the case when Rhaegar left Leone
at the Tower of joy
Rhaegar left men behind to guard the
tower because Rhaegar was certain that
his son would be the prince that was
promised and he wanted to keep him
protected so Rhaegar had arguably the
best swordsman ever Sir Arthur Dayne
left behind to guard Liana and John at
the Tower of joy when Ned Stark and his
men arrived they didn't even want to let
Ned inside the tower even though that
was his sister in there so that just
goes to show you how serious things were
taken but as we saw in season six Ned
and
men killed the guards and Ned goes
inside the tower to find his sister
Lyanna Stark laying in a bed soaked in
blood she had just given birth to
Rhaegar son and she made Ned promise her
that he would protect the baby because
Robert would kill the baby if he ever
found out it was Rey gars child so Ned
kept this secret for 17 years even
though it brought him great shame Ned
Stark raised John Snow as his own son
even though Jon Snow's real parents were
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark Jon
Snow spent his whole life growing up as
a bastard never knowing who his true
mother was because Ned would never talk
about her because he didn't want the
secret getting out and putting John's
life in danger but when Jon Snow left
for the wall and Ned left to go to
King's Landing
Ned promised John that he would tell him
about his mother the next time that they
would see each other unfortunately Ned
Stark died before he could ever reveal
the truth to John but thanks to Game of
Thrones they confirm for us that his
mother wasn't factly on a stark because
lianna handed Ned her baby that would
grow up as Jon Snow after this episode
aired HBO released a chart that trace
Jon Snow's lineage back to leon a stark
and rhaegar targaryen so as of right now
the television show has confirmed that
Rhaegar Plus Liana equals Jon Snow which
would make Jon Snow the Song of Ice and
Fire
but there are still a few more things
that are going to be revealed this
season and they are massive in the very
next episode which is season 7 episode 5
we're gonna get another huge revelation
about Jon Snow's parents thanks to Sam
and gillies discovery the last time we
saw Sam was right after he found out he
was successful at curing jours greyscale
Jorah Mormont was cleared to leave the
Citadel and the archmaester told Sam he
wanted to speak to him in private
he told Sam that he should be proud of
what he did because many maesters had
died trying to cure greyscale the
archmaester then gave Sam another task
he showed Sam a stack of old documents
that were starting to crumble and rot
away and he asked Sam to make copies of
them all before they were destroyed it
was pretty obvious that Sam was going to
find something in these documents that
were very important in episode 5 Sam is
going to decide it's time to leave the
Citadel and head back to Winterfell Sam
must have found out Jon was victorious
during the battle
the bastards so he is heading to the
Starks home in Winterfell you can see
Sam and Gilly leaving old town in these
photos
Sam is now wearing his Knights watch
uniform again so it's clear he's gonna
be heading north you can also see Hart's
main is with him too wrapped up in the
same blanket as before at some point in
episode five Sam and Gilly are gonna
start going through the old papers and
journals that he has but it says Gilly
is actually going to be the one to make
this massive discovery she is gonna look
through an old maesters journal who kept
meticulous records of everything and
this is where we're gonna learn that
Rhaegar Targaryen had his marriage to
Elia Martell annulled it's going to show
that Rey gars first marriage was over
and he got married again to Lyanna stark
and this would make Jon Snow a
legitimate Targaryen in rightful heir to
the Iron Throne this is a huge discovery
that's going to change everything this
is going to change how everyone in the
north looks at him how Daenerys looks at
him and possibly even his own family
when people learned that Jon Snow is a
Targaryen in legitimate heir to the Iron
Throne this is going to be absolutely
shocking
John was never a bastard but he lived
his entire life being treated as one and
this was foreshadowed in the very last
episode Jon Snow and Davos were talking
to missandei about his last name and him
being a bastard Jon told missandei his
last name was snow because his parents
were never married that conversation set
up what we are going to learn in the
next episode Rhaegar was no longer
married to Elia Martell and after that
marriage was annulled Rhaegar then
married Leone a stark which would make
their child a legitimate Targaryen but
this isn't the only thing we're gonna
learn about John this season there will
be one more massive discovery in the
last episode of this season brain stark
will have a flashback that will reveal
several things about the truth of Jon
Snow according to this leak in a season
seven finale Sam Tarly and brain stark
will find out the truth together it says
Sam and brain are gonna be in brains
bedroom at Winterfell and they're gonna
start talking about Jon Snow Sam will
tell brain about his discovery of the
marriage records with Rhaegar and Lyanna
and as Sam and brain are talking about
this brain will start to have multiple
flashbacks at the same time bran will go
back to the Tower of joy and he's gonna
Liyana whisper in a net zero again but
this time bran will hear everything that
she says bran will hear Lian a whisper
the name Aegon Targaryen that is gonna
be Jon Snow's real name bran will also
start to have flashbacks over the
wedding the brain will see Rhaegar and
Lyanna getting married in front of a
tree just like Robb Stark and Talisa did
this is all gonna happen at once very
fast and brain will learn the full truth
about Jon Snow
when bran has the flashback of the
wedding we will hear the High Septon
speak who is marrying Rhaegar and Lyanna
and we will hear them recite their
wedding vows and it's going to be very
clear that Rhaegar and Lyanna were in
love with each other this is going to
confirm that Rhaegar never kidnapped and
raped her but they were in fact married
and in love this will give Jon the
strongest claim to the Iron Throne
although we all know he's never gonna
want to sit on the Iron Throne but by
right it could be his putting him in
front of Daenerys Targaryen same this
could end up causing some real problems
between John and Daenerys when this
truth comes out it's going to send
shockwaves across the Seven Kingdoms
we saw how everyone in the north reacted
when they heard a Targaryen was back in
Westeros wanting to the throne how will
they react when they find out their King
in the north is a legitimate Targaryen
this is gonna be so crazy I can't wait
to see how this plays out I'm also
wondering how Sansa Arya and bran are
gonna start to look at John then this
should be very interesting but I am
dying to know what all of you think
about this especially since most of you
know how accurate the leaks have been
this has to be true - I know some people
hate the fact that Jon Snow's real name
might be Aegon Targaryen but it's
probably going to be true but what do
you all think about this put it down in
the comment section and let me know your
thoughts we should find out in the next
episode whether any of this is true or
not
HBO already released images from episode
five and it shows Sam and Gilly looking
over a bunch of papers together so this
could be the scene where they find out
about Rey gars marriages they foreshadow
Jon Snow's parents marriage in the last
episode when Jon Snow told Masson day
his parents were never married in my
opinion I believe all of this will come
true Jon Snow will be Aegon Targaryen
rightful heir to the Iron Throne
in the prince that was
this is going to be so crazy when this
is revealed I can't wait to see
everyone's reactions when it does happen
I want to thank all of you for stopping
by and watching a video I really
appreciate the tremendous amount of
support you all have shown especially to
everyone on patreon as well I love you
all and I hope you have a great day bye
[Music]
[Music]